- Und?
- Ich weiß nicht …
- Wie ist dein Gefühl?
- Gut.
- Nico!
- Selma!
- Ist die Prüfung schon vorbei?
- Ja, ich bin gerade fertig geworden.
- Oh, ich dachte schon, wir kommen
viel zu spät.
- Ich muss mit dir reden!
- Wir warten draußen.
- Ja! Ja.
- Nico …
- Du musst nichts sagen.
Ich hätte dich niemals in diese Situation
bringen dürfen.
- Welche Situation?
- Du solltest dich niemals zwischen mir und
deinen Eltern entscheiden müssen.
- Das warst nicht allein du.
- Ich weiß.
Und ich wünsch' mir auch, dass wir einfach
so zusammen sein können.
Ich würde alles dafür geben.
- Ich auch.
- Aber das können wir nicht.
Also ich …
ich hab' Angst, dass du es bereuen würdest,
wenn du dich jetzt für mich entscheidest.
- Warum sagst du das?
- Meine Familie ist ein totales Chaos.
Und ich werde nicht der Grund dafür sein,
dass noch eine andere kaputtgeht.
- Machst du Schluss?
- Wir waren nie zusammen, Selma …